ANYTIME HE WANTED TO.
>> Sean: IT GETS MORE SICK
EVERY DAY, TRACE, THANK YOU.
LET'S TURN TO A TERRIBLE SCENE
OUT OF PORTLAND, OREGON.
AND ERUPTING OVER THE WEEKEND,
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN, CHAOS
DESCENDING ON PARTS OF THE CITY
OF PORTLAND.
AND CLASHING WITH MEMBERS OF THE
FRENCH NATIONALIST WHITE
SUPREMACIST, BIGOT GROUPS TO
EACH AND EVERY SINGLE PERSON ON
EITHER SIDE THAT HAS AN EXTREME
AGENDA, I WANT ALL OF YOU, YOU
MUST STOP THIS INSANITY, THIS
LAWLESSNESS.
THE POLICE NEED TO STOP THIS AND
ENDED AND DROP IT WHEN IT
STARTS.
THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR IS
UNACCEPTABLE, IT IS INSANE, IT
IS DESPICABLE, VIOLENCE,
EXTREMISM AND HURTING OUR
COUNTRY.
LET'S NOT FORGET, THE POLITICAL
DISAGREEMENTS BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY, WE ARE ALL AMERICANS.
REMEMBER, WE ARE ALL CREATED
EQUAL.
WE ARE ALL ONE NATION UNDER GOD
AND IN THE UNITED STATES
POLITICAL DIFFERENCES, WE SAW
THEM AT THE BALLOT BOX.
NO CHEATING OR HILLARY RUSSIAN
LIES AND PALMED THEM OFF AS
TRUTH.
THAT IS A PROBLEM.
WERE PEOPLE ABUSING POWER BUT
WHAT MATTERS HERE IS WE CAN HAVE
A COMPLETE OPEN DISCUSSION OF
IDEAS AND IDEALS.
WE DON'T NEED BASEBALL BATS,
FISTS AND MAIZE.
THIS SHOW WILL CONDEMN HATRED ON
ANY SIDE.
WHITE SUPREMACY, BIGOTRY YOU
HAVE NO PLACE IN SOCIETY, NONE
WHATSOEVER.
PEOPLE CHANTING WHAT DO WE WANT
DEAD COPS, WE WANT THEM NOW?
YOU ARE RADICALS HURTING OUR
COUNTRY.
YOU ARE PUTTING THE MEN AND
WOMEN THAT PROTECT AND SERVE US
AT RISK.
YOU ARE ANTI-POST-EXTREMIST AND
THE SAME GOES TO YOU.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE IN COMMON SICK,
UGLY EVIL IDEOLOGIES.
WE HAVE TO REMAIN ONE
UNITED STATES, GOD'S GREATEST